Speaker 1: We have some incredible text messages
that have been leaked.
You may remember a guy named Mark Meadows.
Mark Meadows was Donald Trump's final chief
of staff.
Last thing up through the end of Trump's presidency.
CNN has obtained more than 2000, about 2300,
in fact, text messages involving Mark Meadows.
And what they expose is truly incredible.
What we have learned.
And we're going to look at some of these text
messages momentarily.
They were brainstorming how to lie about the
Trump riots, how to cover their you know,
what's about the Trump riots?
They were coordinating a response that they
knew wasn't actually based, in fact.
And we're going to look at a couple of these
text messages.
These are fascinating.
Sean HANNITY, the Fox News propagandist, texted
Mark Meadows and said, Is North Carolina going
to be okay?
And Mark Meadows said to HANNITY, stress,
every vote matters.
Get out and vote on radio.
And HANNITY responds, Yes, sir.
Quite literally.
Fox propagandist taking his marching orders
from the chief of staff of the President of
the United States.
We suspected it.
But here we have the proof.
Sean HANNITY responded on it.
Any particular place?
We need a push.
And Meadows wrote back, Pennsylvania, North
Carolina, Arizona, Nevada.
And HANNITY says, Got it everywhere.
There were some texts with Matt SCHLAPP and
Mark Meadows, which aren't super interesting.
On November 6th, just after the election,
Jason Miller was putting out talking points
so that others could argue that something
fishy and Trump probably won texting.
One other key data point.
In 2016, Trump received 15.5% of the vote
in Philly County.
Today, he's at 18.3%.
So he did better in that county.
In 2016, Philly County made up 11.3% of the
total vote.
As it currently stands, Philly County only
makes up 10.2% of the statewide vote tally,
so Trump performed better in a smaller share.
Santorum was just making this point on CNN
cuts hard against the urban vote stealing
narrative.
Okay, so they're coming up with these ideas
to try to support the claim false, not based
in evidence that Trump actually won.
Rick Perry texted Mark Meadows.
We have the data driven program that can clearly
show where the fraud was committed.
This is the silver bullet.
Pam Bondi misspelled, has seen and agrees
all day, every day just sending these things
back and forth, back and forth, back and forth.
Ginni Thomas, the wife of Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas, was texting Mark Meadows,
trying to understand the Sidney Powell distancing.
Remember, this was when the Trump campaign
said, oh, Sidney Powell, that crazy lawyer,
she's on her own.
She's not really with us.
And Meadows wrote back, She doesn't have anything.
Or at least she won't share if she does.
To which Ginni Thomas responds.
Wow.
Some other text messages that I want to look
at with you.
Donald Trump jr texted Mark Meadows on January
6th as the riots were taking place and said
he's got to condemn this s asap.
The Capitol Police tweet is not enough.
Mark Meadows writes back, I'm pushing it hard.
I agree.
This his one?
You go to the mattresses on.
They will try to eff his entire legacy on
this if it gets worse.
Don Jr.
Seemingly unable to talk sense into his own
father, was texting mark meadows saying the
one tweet isn't enough.
They're going to screw him on this.
Mick Mulvaney texted Mark Meadows saying,
Mark, he needs to stop this now.
Can I do anything to help?
Republican Congressman William Timmons tested
texted the president needs to stop this ASAP.
They all knew how bad this was and they knew
it was Trumpists and they knew it was bad
for Trump on January 6th.
Reince Priebus texted Mark Meadows saying,
Tell them to go home.
They all knew what it was and how bad it looked.
They all knew it.
And yet, publicly, they continued to spin
a different line.
And that night, January 6th at night.
The very Fox hosts who were texting with Meadows
and they all knew it was Trumpists.
They all knew Trump wasn't doing enough to
stop it.
The fact that he instigated it, they went
on Fox and they said, Oh, you know, it could
have been Antifa.
Could have been Black Lives Matter.
Who knows what it was, who it was.
So recently, Democratic Congressman Jamie
Raskin said he now is convinced that this
was a coordinated effort to cause these riots
and then to run interference.
He says they have the evidence, they have
the testimony, and it's going to come out.
And now we have the texts.
Whether this is all of it or part of it, we
don't yet know.
But the story Republicans wove.
We knew it was not accurate.
That's not a shock.
I mean, we're now what is it, 15 months in,
we knew that they weren't telling the truth.
But now we know that it was a coordinated
and knowing effort to deceive, not they just
had the wrong understanding of what happened.
It's
truly incredible.